If you've got a great idea but need the cash to make it go,...
...well then you'd better start working on your elevator pitch.
What is an elevator pitch?
It's the term used for the two-minute presentation,...
...the exact amount of time it takes to go from the lobby...
...to the investor's office on the top floor to capture investor interest.
Get it right and they'll invite you into the boardroom.
Get it wrong and they'll call security.
What makes a good elevator pitch?
A good elevator pitch is made up of two key elements.
First, you have to lay out the paying statement.
What problem is it that you are trying to solve?
Second, you must show the value proposition.
How does your venture solve that problem?
That may sound easy, but it's not.
Every great elevator pitch must meet four key tests.
First, it must be succinct. After all, this guy is only going to give you two minutes.
Number two, it must be easy to understand. There's no room for tech talk in an elevator pitch.
Both your grandma and your grandkids have to get it.
Number three, it must be greed-inducing.
After all, investors want to make money and lots of it.
Number four, it has to be irrefutable.
If your elevator pitch leaves investors with more questions than answers, well,...
...you better go back to the drawing board.